[MUSIC PLAYING]
This technology has been used
in a wide variety of fields.
I know it has an application
in manufacturing,
and but the way that we,
as a club, borderline
uses AR is basically
to kind of reveal
second meaning or hidden layer
behind the student murals.
The way that it works is you
see this animation playing
on your phone through
the app that we use.
It can reveal something that
previously wasn't there.
One day I just
realized that this,
because of this kind of desire
to know these microorganisms
better, I use the term empathy.
How do I empathize
with the bacteria
that is constituting me in a
very material and literal way.
And then I suddenly
realized that I would never
reach that state of empathy
with my bacteria in a Petri dish
because then it's a specimen,
and it's specifying itself
as a specimen.
And that power dynamic
and that relationship,
that would never
constitute something
close to empathy, or
wonder, or surprise,
because the object
is already known.
There's a way that data is kind
of treated as found material.
It's just kind of out there.
But you know, it's not exactly
the same as just picking
something up off the street.
It's something that's
usually highly integrated
into people's lives.
And so there's these like
questions of consent and power
that are baked in.
And I think that's where
they converge for me.
Being an artist and
being creative at MIT,
also like understanding
the ethics and implications
of the technologies that we
use, the technologies we create,
and the technologies
that are on our service,
let's say, for creation.
So for example, got like this
like microgravity flights.
They consume a lot of like
immense amounts of fossil fuel,
for example.
There's a lot of CO2 emissions
out of these experiments.
And then it makes us wonder
and putting a balance
what, what does it mean, right.
And what does it mean?
Is the work that we're
doing, are the questions
that we're asking
is relevant enough
to also fit in that balance and
make it in these perspectives
that we need to be
wondering about,
that we need to
be creating with.